- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna start talking
about exceptions to the octet rule,
which we've talked about
in many other videos.
The octet rule is this notion
that atoms tend to react in ways
that they're able to
have a full outer shell.
They're able to have
eight valence electrons.
Now, we've already talked
about some exceptions,
things like hydrogen.
Its outer shell is that first shell
which gets full with two electrons.
So it's trying to get to that duet rule.
But as we'll see, there
are other exceptions.
Boron and aluminum, for example,
they can form stable
molecules where the boron
or the aluminum only have six
valence electrons, not eight.
And there are exceptions
in the other direction.
As you get to the third period and beyond,
we'll actually see atoms
that can maintain more
than eight valence electrons.
And we're actually going to see an example
of that with xenon.
So let's just go into a few examples.
Given what I've told you,
see if you can come up
with the Lewis diagram
for aluminum hydride.
So aluminum hydride has one aluminum
and three hydrogens.
See if you can draw the
Lewis diagram for that.
All right, now let's do this together.
So the first thing you wanna do is account
for all of the valence electrons.
Aluminum's outer shell is the third shell,
so the third period here,
and it has one, two,
three valence electrons.
And then we have three hydrogens,
and each hydrogen has
one valence electron.
And so you add all of this up together,
three plus three is equal
to six valence electrons
in aluminum hydride.
Now, the next step after that is
to try to draw the structure
with some covalent bonds.
We don't wanna make
hydrogen our central atom.
That would be very atypical.
And so let's put aluminum in the center.
And then we're gonna have three hydrogens.
So one, two, and three.
And then let's put some
covalent bonds in here.
And so let's see, how
many valence electrons
have we now accounted for?
This is two in this covalent bond.
Another two gets us to four.
Another two gets us to six.
So we have just accounted for
all six valence electrons.
So we have no more valence
electrons to play with.
Let's think about how the
various atoms are doing.
So the hydrogens are all
meeting their duet rule.
These two electrons in this
bond are hanging around hydrogen
and around the aluminum.
But from hydrogen's point
of view, it has a full duet,
that hydrogen as well and
that hydrogen as well.
But notice the aluminum over here,
it has two, four, six electrons,
valence electrons around it,
and so it's not a full octet.
But aluminum hydride is actually something
that has been observed.
Let's think about another example.
Let's think about xenon pentafluoride.
Xenon pentafluoride cations,
a positively charged ion here.
Pause this video and see
if you can draw the
Lewis diagram for this.
All right, now let's do this together.
If any of this seems unfamiliar,
I encourage you to watch the video
on introduction to drawing Lewis diagrams.
But what we'd wanna do is first think
about our valence electrons.
So xenon right over here,
it's actually a noble gas.
It already has a full
octet in its outer shell,
so it has eight valence electrons.
So xenon has eight valence electrons.
And then fluorine, we've
seen this multiple times,
has one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven valence electrons,
but there's five of them.
So five times seven.
I'm gonna be drawing a
lot of electrons in this.
So this gives us a total of eight plus 35,
which is 43 valence electrons.
But we have to be careful.
This is a cation.
It is a positively charged molecule.
It has a positive one charge.
So we have to take one
electron away because of that.
So let's take away one valence
electron to get that cation.
And so we are left with 42.
42 valence electrons.
So the next step is to
try to draw its structure
with some basic single covalent bonds.
And xenon would be our
preferred central atom
because fluorine is more electronegative.
It's actually the most
electronegative element.
So let's put xenon in the middle,
and then let's put some
fluorines around it,
five of them to be specific.
So one, two,
three, four.
I'm having trouble writing an F.
Four and then five fluorines.
And now let me make five covalent bonds.
One, two, three, four, five.
So just like that, I have
accounted for 10 valence electrons
because you have two valence electrons
in each of these covalent bonds,
two, four, six, eight, 10.
So let me subtract 10 valence electrons.
And then we are left with
32 valence electrons.
Now, the next step is to
try to allocate some more
of these valence electrons
to the terminal atom
so that they get to a full octet.
So let me do that to the fluorines.
Each of these fluorines
already are participating
in a covalent bond, so they already have
two valence electrons
hanging out with them,
so let's give 'em each six more.
So let's give that fluorine six,
and that fluorine gets six,
and that fluorine gets
six valence electrons,
and then last but not least,
this fluorine gets six valence electrons.
So I have just given away
six valence electrons
to each of five fluorine atoms.
So that is 30 valence electrons
that I have just allocated.
And then what does that leave me with?
That leaves me with two valence electrons
that have gone unallocated.
And the only place to now
put them is on the xenon.
And as I said, things that are lower down
in that periodic table of elements,
especially as we get
below the third period,
these can defy the octet rule.
Xenon already has 10 valence electrons,
and I'm about to allocate it
two more to it just like that.
So you allocate those two more.
And then we have allocated
all of our valence electrons.
And I wanna make sure I
remind myself and everyone
that this is a cation.
So I have to put that plus
charge just like this,
but this is something
that has been observed
where you can actually have
a central atom like this
that goes beyond an octet
number of valence electrons.
In this case, it has two, four, six,
eight, 10, 12 valence electrons.
Now, an interesting question
is how do these atoms
that are in the third
period or beyond handle more
than eight valence electrons?
And it is a matter of debate,
but some chemists believe
that it's possible
because they're able to
place their electrons
in their empty valence d-orbitals.
But once again, this is controversial
in the chemistry community.